[Music]
well the unlv football program is
finally going to open its season this
saturday on the road in carson
california to face san diego state
boy it's been a crazy ops season but as
kevin martin tells us tonight the
players are just happy to be playing
and rolling with the punches just go out
there
i got eight games shoot that's good
enough to me
the rebels open their 2020 campaign this
saturday and while it won't be your
typical college football season
senior running back charles williams is
grateful to have a season
at all as a team i'm trying to make sure
everybody is locked in because
yeah this might be my last year but
there's a lot of stuff going on after me
like you got to keep this momentum going
no matter how the season goes
like every other team the rebels have
had to roll with the punches
and while it's been an adjustment not
only with the new normal but with the
new coaching staff
they feel like they're headed in the
right direction i mean everything is
different as far as you know how we
watch film
how we even practice you know we're
always trying to social distance um so i
feel like that is a disadvantage
but the advantage that we do have is
that you know there's a different type
of culture here
i feel like everybody's mindset is kind
of you know coming together towards you
know
just winning and working hard in
addition to all the changes there will
also be no fans in the stands on
saturday which the players say
won't have an effect on how they play to
be honest when you're on that field
you're making plays you're not thinking
about the fans you're thinking about the
opponent
so i don't think it's going to be that
big of a concern it doesn't really
matter whether the fans are there
or not you know our goal is still going
to be the same unlv and san diego state
kickoff at 7 30 saturday
and if the last two meetings are any
indication how this one will play out
we're in for a real treat i feel like
this year is going to be you know
something
where we you know go out there and put
our best foot forward and go battle with
sdsu it's going to be a really good game
kevin martin 8 sports now
all right and as kevin reported rebels
home opener the 31st kicks off at 7
30 there will be a limited number of
tickets on sale to the public
but just like fans unlv is awaiting word
from the health committee
to green light the plan for fans to
attend that game
well the raiders are feeling pretty good
they had a week off week to kind of get
back on the field and get ready for the
big game coming up this sunday that's
going to be tampa bay
the win over the chiefs will go a long
way in helping the raiders prepare for
the rest of the season
looking like they're figuring some
things out getting people back from
injury and
it all translates into that huge win
over the defending world champion so
when
the raiders kick off with the bucks look
at this here they'll be facing with the
best defenses in the national
football league how about these numbers
here fewest total yards allowed per game
fewest yards per play
fewest rushing yards allowed per game
fewest first downs allowed per game
and they're tied for second in the
league with 11 takeaways boy sportsbooks
could make some great prop bets
with those numbers the team announced
they've signed former cowboy and pass
rusher
david irving to uh to the practice squad
he'll rejoin the raiders defensive line
coach rod marinelli
who was the cowboys defensive
coordinator and defensive line coach
when
irving played with the cowboys there
irving hasn't played those since
2018. could it come down to special
teams remember when daniel carlson was
called upon to boot this long field goal
to preserve the win against the saints
he's kicking in a climate control
facility now not a baseball field
with winds swirling around in oakland
makes a huge difference
very different kicking off dirt in the
wind in oakland um
but i mean we're happy to be here in
vegas and you know the
field's obviously unbelievable the
stadium is unbelievable
as a kicker you don't have to worry
about conditions that it's obviously
very nice could have come down to
special teams hey we'll show you what
happened in game one of the world series
that unfolds they're playing right now
in texas
dodgers looking to win the title for the
first time in 32 years
ray is looking for their first ever
world series title
the sports books tampa at one time was a
28-1
long shot to win it now there's four
wins away we'll be right back